[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show everybody um
it appears it is not only producer pat
not watching the olympics um
very very low ratings for the olympics
compared to the 2018
kind of early numbers um
it's all
it's all kind of weird also because some
of the stuff is streaming on peacock now
which is like the separate network and
online streaming it's it's still very
early in these olympics
but it's not seeming
like there is significant interest here
and on the 2022 opening ceremony
only 8.7 million people watched and it
you know i i continue to think pat that
there's another story here that's not
often mentioned which is
depending on where the olympics are held
the timing in the united states allows
for live but at a weird time
live or
these kind of repackaged it's meant to
look kind of live but it's all happened
hours ago
and
the opening ceremony was carried in one
of these packaged pre-taped things
and i think that even if it looks and
feels live people know that it's not and
i think it just reduces interest i
really do yeah it could be a number of
reasons we've also seen a waning
interest in sports over the past couple
of years yeah for whatever reason ever
since the pandemic started people have
just been not tuning into sports as much
there could be a number of different
factors maybe because sports disappeared
for a little bit and so people got used
to not watching them it could be
some of the black lives matter protests
affecting things maybe that's why people
started tuning out a little bit but yeah
i mean this olympic olympics compared to
previous ones like i remember the 2008
olympics that was also in china that was
huge yeah everyone was watching that
michael phelps was winning all these
gold medals and for whatever reason
people just aren't watching anymore and
this also was true for the tokyo
olympics last year the other thing i
mean you know our conversation about
this is very u.s centric i understand
that in other countries it's different
because you're in a different time zone
which may be more convenient or the
athletes from your country may be doing
well but the u.s did not start off well
in the early events either and sometimes
what allows interest to build
are interesting stories about athletes
or teams related to to american you know
athletes and it's also starting very
slow there in terms of medals and events
so it's just all pointing to being kind
of very meh
yeah the us tends to do really well when
it comes to the summer olympics but not
so much the winter olympics we get our
wins here and there but other countries
tend to shine when it comes to the
winter olympics but i honestly do feel
bad in a sense it's not going to make me
actually start to watch the games or
anything like that but i just feel as
though these athletes they work their
whole lives to become olympians you know
maybe they're on the bobsledding team or
they're on the curling team or whatever
the case may be
they don't really have a professional
future in the sport outside of the
olympics which is probably it for them
and i you know in theory want these
sports to continue right i want there to
be professional athletes who are able to
go to the olympics and be successful in
these different fields i like that that
exists but i'm just not caring enough to
watch myself no i know what you mean i i
also saw a really disturbing thing just
i mean this is like kind of neither here
nor there but i saw an aerial shot
of one of the i think it was a ski
jumping track i don't know if you saw
this picture pat where it's basically
like a concrete jungle
urban smog hellish situation
and you see a little white line and you
have to look closely and
the ski jump it's not like on a mountain
and it's it's just literally they've
built a ski jumping thing with with what
i assume is fake snow
in the middle of nuclear reactors like
there's literally nuclear the you know
the typical like from the simpsons the
two nuclear
uh things and it's just like it just
seems depressing to see it in this way
and that's for the event itself it's not
just for practice runs i think it's for
the event yeah i do i think from what i
read i think it's for the event it's
weird that's crazy if you had to pick a
winter sport that you would become an
olympian in which would you choose oh i
don't you know so i think i would
probably say
an individual sport because it just
seems like
hockey
there's it seems like it might be more
interesting to be doing i'm recognized
individually for this in some way
so maybe um
i don't know like
the ski the downhill skiing is
interesting to me and it's very high
speed and kind of exciting so that
that's kind of cool i don't know right
hockey is a little bit of a cop-out
because then you can also be an nhl
player for example so it's a little bit
of a cheap answer is snowshoeing one of
the sports i think i would be best at
that i don't think i don't know if it is
that's the other thing by the way it's
not always the same sports over time
sports are rotated in and out and that
causes a lot of controversy because
sometimes people are like well there's
this is just there's no basis for
comparison there's no real rea what are
we comparing to is this person really
that good it's just this is the first
year they've done this and i think that
bothers some people as well oh totally
and especially if you commit your live
life to a certain sport and then they
cancel it they just they get rid of it
from the olympics like that's not fair
especially when you reach your prime
athletically when you become 18 years
old and ready to compete in the olympics
and all of a sudden they don't have your
sport anymore they can't do that to you
so the other aspect of the olympic
situation i want to talk about and this
this is just this is really not good
um you know there's a global pandemic
still going on we're hoping soon it will
be endemic rather than pandemic but in
practice it's not really you know for
the purposes of the olympics they're
still testing and quarantining
there are
hellish stories about the quarantine
hotels for athletes claiming that they
have
not nearly enough food and inedible
meals
no ability to train or kind of stay in
in shape for their sport where they need
to uh
quarantine when they arrive
some of the athletes are testing
positive
and then they are ending up in these
horrifying quarantine situations people
talking about
stomachaches and all sorts of different
issues as a result of the food for the
quarantining that is taking place
that it's bizarre food charred meat on a
bone no vegetables in many cases and
like it it just seems completely hellish
in every way
and it again just raises questions of
like
did it really make sense to do this
given that this was going to be the
situation as far as covet goes
obviously it's tough to cancel though
especially when this is years and years
in the making and you don't know what
the state of the pandemic is going to be
even a year out i mean you could assume
okay it's going to be the winter so we
could have another wave of this thing it
could be severe but is that enough to
cancel it on maybe not and uh it's
interesting how even like a percentage
of these athletes are testing positive
because we've talked for a long time
about china lying about the numbers
apparently according to their statistics
only about 40 to 100 people in the
entire country of one plus billion are
getting coveted every single day right
that just doesn't add up even if it's
impossible to who could possibly believe
that they'll say we've had a covet zero
policy but it just it's not believable
at all
yeah even if three of these athletes and
coaches are testing positive every
single day and that gets factored into
the numbers statistically that means
that so many more of the population are
also getting this thing so yeah i mean
it's so obvious that they're they're
lying about the numbers at this point uh
but yeah i mean that would be awful too
like we were talking about how it would
be terrible if you commit to a sport and
then they get rid of it from the
olympics it would be even worse maybe if
like you're at the olympics you're ready
to go then you test positive and you
can't even compete i mean
the other thing that's being alleged is
that the athletes are getting worse food
than the non-athletes which i i don't
know why it would be but there was this
situation where um a i believe it was a
belgian athlete said
that their food was like just absolutely
terrible and they started to notice that
there were different looking boxes left
outside of some other rooms and then was
able to talk to like a coach
and the coach was getting fresh fruit
and prawns with broccoli and also i
don't even like why would the athletes
not get the better food i don't even
it's all crazy here's a cynical reason
because they don't want these foreign
athletes to perform well maybe they're
giving the chinese athletes the best
food possible but they're giving these
foreign athletes not so great food i
mean it just seems so obvious that that
would be figured out though yeah because
these athletes have social media pages
they can easily talk about how bad the
food is it's not like they could keep
that a secret no you're right it's all
very bizarre and i'm guessing that in
the next few days like in the last 48
hours a lot of this stuff started coming
out and going public i'm guessing in the
next 48 hours we're going to find out a
lot more about
how some of these things are being
handled but not a great situation for
many different people
in a number of different ways
in the united states
alcohol
is coming back to planes
and understandably flight attendants are
worried that it's going to create an
unsafe work environment now i would say
an even more unsafe work environment for
flight attendants and as many of you may
or may not know
there are airlines
that stopped serving alcohol during the
pandemic
different airlines have and are bringing
it back at different times the latest is
that southwest airlines will start
serving alcohol again
uh eight days from now on february 16th
and um
airlines are
wanting to do this presumably to restore
a sense of normalcy to make their
airline more attractive and to make
money right at the end of the day
alcohol on flights is very very
profitable
and um
flight attendants are worried and i
would be too i mean when you look at the
number of disturbances and unruly
passengers mask refusers and all these
different things even when drinking
their sprite on every flight i've been
on people are playing fast and loose
holding the glass like this the whole
time and keeping their mask down for an
hour under the guys that they're
actively drinking what do you think is
going to happen when those drinks have
alcohol in them i mean i i sympathize
with the flight attendants here i think
it makes sense to wait like i think it's
fine to have alcohol on planes in
general but maybe let's wait until the
mask requirements aren't in place
anymore that's what i was going to ask
people do you think that alcohol should
come back only when masks are no longer
needed i don't i don't know like does
that make sense maybe it does i'm not
sure i would expect that yes because i'd
imagine that a good portion of these
incidents where people get unruly have
to do with the fact that they have to
wear the mask and then you know if
they're wearing it below their nose or
whatever the person next to them yells
at them they go back and forth flight
attendants get involved
certainly people can get upset about
different things on a plane just because
there's stresses from traveling right
this existed long before the pandemic
but obviously uh the masks are an
aggregate aggravating factor in this i'm
trying to remember in all of the flights
you've done since in the mask era have
you have you had unruly passenger
incidents or non-compliant people or
stuff like that
not really i mean a few people who were
instructed a few times to wear their
masks properly but
nothing too crazy i almost want to see
that happen because it would be
entertaining but that could also
backfire because maybe we'd have to do
an emergency landing somewhere or get
the flight delayed so maybe i would just
be asking for it i've had everything you
can imagine i mean no no physical
altercations but every people who just
took their mask off when the plane took
off and then just walked around back and
forth to the bathroom with no mask and
very late in the flight they were told
you got to wear a mask and then they
would cover their face with a napkin
i mean just just absurd uh people um
playing coy with the with the glass i
had one situation not not directly
related to covid but when i was flying
back from this was when i went to spain
and i connected in frankfurt on my
frankfur frankfurt flight coming back
uh i boarded the plane with my
girlfriend and put our bags up right
above our seats as as any normal person
would do
and then more people boarded and then
eventually a couple boarded and they
wanted to put their bags above their
seats we were separated by the aisle and
there was no room there because other
people had boarded now how it goes it's
how it goes there was plenty of room
above the seat right behind them but
they they wanted their bags right above
their seat and these just starts moving
my bag and i stand up and i say excuse
me that's my bag is there an issue and
the guy says well this i'm trying to put
my bag here and i say oh the overheads
aren't assigned to specific seats
there's room there and there's room
there you could take one step back or
one step forward and the guy said well
you're you don't have the right and i
was like the right to what sir i don't
have the right to what and i said did
you want me to move my bag where do you
want me to put my tell me where to put
my bag and i'll move it and then his
wife like talked him out and he just was
grumpy and he put it's like dude just
this is the way it works you you use the
space that's available and then you
gotta look for space that's it
yeah that just seems like such an
unnecessary confrontation completely
glad it didn't escalate and i'm glad
that you know presumably that guy didn't
have too much alcohol in him although i
guess i can't say for sure i don't think
he did there's also the question about
whether you actually are salty over the
fact that they're bringing alcohol back
to some of these airlines just because
you're not allowed to drink alcohol on a
plane because of your vasovagal incident
that you had yeah i don't i don't drink
on planes anymore after i i had a glass
of wine and then fainted once i was also
highly dehydrated i would probably be
fine but just to be safe i'm not
drinking on planes no that that's really
not part of it i just i'm annoyed
because
other people get annoying when they
drink on planes that's really that
simple i just thought you were jealous
no if you can't drink on a plane then no
one should be able to not at all not at
all that's not not a factor whatsoever
um so there it is alcohol slowly coming
back
um
i am reading more and more about states
dropping mass guidelines we talked about
new jersey yesterday california is going
to be doing it but this is like in
schools and indoor places i think that
the plane masking is going to be with us
for quite some time the plane masking oh
oh okay i understand i was thinking
p-l-a-i-n oh i see uh but yeah probably
planes and trains
and automobiles that aren't yours yeah
they'll continue the masking rules you
think through the end of the year at
least
that's a good guess yeah because like
even when they lifted the mask
requirements over the summer after a
good portion of the population got
vaccinated and cases were really low
yeah we still kept some mask
requirements
you know transportation was one of them
so i would say the end of the year that
sounds like a good time i think at
minimum it's going to stick around until
then and you know what it's fine i mean
on overnight flights i i think for
trying to sleep
it is better not to wear a mask but i'm
fine with it and when i fly
i'm agreeing to that as a term so i'm
not going to buy a ticket and click i
understand i gotta wear a mask and then
not wear it if these are the rules i'm
gonna follow the rules otherwise i won't
fly that's my perspective
all right that's it for today see
everybody tomorrow